- A horse knows what
they're supposed to do
by what your legs are asking.
The way you sit in that saddle,
the way your legs move, the
way your calves tighten,
the way your feet bump a horse,
all of those things are communication.
I guess you could say
I'm at a disadvantage.
I can only use my hands and my voice
to communicate with my horse
because I can't move my legs.
(horse neighing)
My name is Amberley Snyder,
and I'm a professional barrel racer.
Barrel racing is a speed
event in the world of rodeo.
There are three barrels
set up in the arena
and you do a cloverleaf
pattern around those barrels
and it's all timed, so
the fastest time wins.
Barrel racing isn't just what I do;
my horses and competing in
rodeo, it's a part of who I am.
I started riding at three and competing
in barrel racing at the age of seven.
Just have loved it ever since then,
I mean I've done it all
through junior rodeo days,
up into high school, college rodeo,
and now into the professional level.
Only days before I was going
to buy my pro rodeo permit,
I was in a rollover car accident
where I was ejected and broke my back,
which paralyzed me from the waist down.
Doctors told me slim to no chance
that I would be able to walk again.
It was going to be impossible to ride.
That wasn't an option for me,
riding was what I was going to do,
I didn't care what had to happen.
After I started doing therapy,
sensation started coming back in my legs.
When I got back on my
horses, that only got better.
The very first time I
got back on my horse,
I realized that it wasn't
going to be the same.
The biggest change is balance.
I went through modifications,
seatbelt on my saddle,
Velcro straps around my legs,
all these pieces that made
it so that I could ride.
The horse I have now, his
name is Legacy, aka Legs.
I named him that because
that's what he becomes
every time I get to leave
my wheelchair in my trailer.
I now have to use my hands and my voice
where my legs were now
a piece I couldn't use.
He's the one that has made all of
those impossible things possible.
I mean he is the one that
has brought me back into
that arena to be not just a
participant but a competitor.
To make the national finals rodeo
and be a world champion barrel
racer is my biggest goal.
I've won over 70 buckles
before my accident
but this buckle, this is my first buckle
I won since my accident.
Took me six years to get to win this one.
There's been points
where I wanted to quit,
there's been points
where it's been too hard.
It doesn't matter what the odds are,
it doesn't matter what people say,
you're the only one that gets
to decide what you're capable of.
(uplifting guitar music)